في ظل ضغط دولي تواجهه روسيا جراء حربها
على اوكرانيا وما اعقبها من عقوبات غربيه
تبدو موسكو متحمسه لتعزيز علاقتها مع
بيجين علاقه يقول الرئيس الروسي لدى
استقباله كبير الدبلوماسيين الصينيين انها
بلغت افاقا جديده اما الخارجيه الروسيه
فوصفت موقف الصين من الحرب بالمتوازن مع
التاكيد على تطابق رؤيتي الدولتين الى حد
كبير ورحبت المتحدثه باسمها بمبادره الصين
للعب دور فعال في حل الازمه الاوكرانيه
مبادره لم تتضح بعد ملامحها ولا الموقف
الاوكراني منها لكن تنظر اليها بعين الربا
بحكم التقارب الصيني الروسي تقارب في
علاقات كانت محكومه بتنافس على النفوذ في
وسط اسيا وتعامل شبه الدي حولته التغيرات
الدوليه الى تحالف موضوعي يجادل كثيرون
انه لحظي لا يجمع بين الصين وروسيا تحالف
رسمي لكن العلاقات بدات اقوى تدريجيا خلال
السنوات الماضيه ورفعت الحرب على اوكرانيا
من ايقاع نموها وتوسع التعاون ليشمل
المجالات الاقتصاديه والعسكريه والسياسيه
لكن ميزان العلاقات مختل بشكل كبير
ومتزايد لصالح بيجين سياسيا لم تصف الصين
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا بالغزو ولم
تصوت ضد روسيا في اي من قرارات مجلس الامن
التي تناولت الحرب وكاله بلومبر سبق ونشرت
ان الصين طلبت من روسيا تاجيل بدء حربها
على اوكرانيا الى حين انتهاء اولمبياد
بيجين الشتويه عام 2022 والتي انتهت في
العشرين من فبراير وهو ما يبدو ان روسيا
استجابت له حيث اعلنت بدا عمليتها
العسكريه في الرابع والعشرين من الشهر
نفسه اي بعد اربعه ايام من نهايه الدوره
الشتويه للالعاب
مسؤولون رؤوس تحدثوا عن ان تاجيل العمليه
العسكريه سمح لاوكرانيا بالاستعداد اكثر
للحرب وسهل وصول معدات عسكريه غربيه ما
عقد من حسابات الحرب من بدايتها بالنسبه
الى الروس اقتصاديا لا يتجاوز حجم
الاقتصاد الروسي عشر الاقتصاد الصيني
ويقول خبراء ان اعتماد موسكو على بيجين
سياسيا واقتصاديا يعني امكانيه انتزاع
تنازلات منها بشكل لم يكن ممكنا في السابق
خصوصا في ملف الامدادات الطاقيه التي
تحتاج اليها الصين وملف التنازع على
النفوذ في منطقه اسيا الوسطى حيث تتعارض
رؤيه الدولتين للمنطقه ما يعني سياده رؤيه
الصين الحزام والطريق على حساب روسيا
ومشروعها في منطقه تعتبرها مجالها الحيوي
كما تشكل العلاقات مع الهند نقطه خلاف
اخرى حيث ترى فيها الصين اكبر منافس
اقليمي لها وتحاول تحجيم نفوذها فيما تصير
موسكو على الحفاظ على شراكتها مع دلهي
التي تعتبرها من اكبر شركائها التجاريين